Okay, I hope you're enjoying the case study so far. What
I'd like to do here, is set us up for the
portion of the case study where you're going to be cleaning
your data. Now, before we dive into the code, what I'd
like to do is just remind you where the documentation is
for the OpenStreetMap data set. The easiest place to find it
is through the wiki and I purposely kept this page a
little small so positionally you'll remember where to find the documentation.
So what we are looking for here is the OSM XML link. Okay, and I'll just make
the page big enough so you can actually read
the documentation. Now what I am interested in, you
see, is the way in which the XML file
was organized into nodes and ways. And also, relations.
Now the thing to note here is that our
data, is setup so that nodes can be tagged.
As can ways, alright? And the semantics of this type of structure here,
is that these tags, because they're nested within this node Actually tag this
particular node here and the same is true with way tags that we find.
So here we're seeing tags that are actually describing this particular way
here. Okay? So it's actually pretty straight forward,
but in terms of parsing it, we have to
remember that in order to understand exactly what a
given tag, tag describes. Okay, so what I'd like
to do in this example, is talk a little
bit about cleaning street names. Now back in Lesson
Three, we actually looked quickly at an example of
auditing street names. We're going to take that example
a little bit further. And here we're actually going to apply it to ways. Now
ways in this data set are streets. They're
essentially paths through a city of one kind
or another. So avenues, squares, commons, other sorts of areas that are a way of
getting from one place to another is essentially
how way is defined in this data set.